I almost can't believe I'm saying this
but this past weekend t food challenge
ninja - a fight that's right two of the
biggest gamers on planet Earth might be
getting in the ring let me tell you how
we got to this point all right so before
we get into this dramatic weekend from
the world of fortnight I've got to
remind you if you want to see a story
covered by the don't at me team make
sure to hit us up on our tips email
subscribe to the channel and maybe
you'll see me and Devin up here telling
your story also who you can make sure to
tweet at me and tell me who you think is
gonna win this fight okay so this entire
mess it started on Saturday morning at
about 9:45 Pacific time right around
then ninjas Twitter got hacked and well
what took place is unfortunately what
you see every single time someone's
Twitter gets hacked some slurs and some
drama getting stirred up and amidst the
Twitter shitstorm the hacker took aim at
T foo in an attempt to rekindle one of
fortnight's longest-running beefs the
hacker tweeted at T food from ninjas
account using the hashtag t foo vs ninja
saying I'd clap his ass now I have to be
honest when I saw this I laughed out
loud
immediately the idea of ninja and T foo
throwing down is just so funny to me
it's like the most awkward cringe gamer
fight of all time but maybe the best
part is that it didn't stop there T food
jumped on the opportunity to make a hack
Twitter account into something real and
made a video actually called out ninja
and asking him to fight alright yeah I
woke up this morning to a whole bunch of
heat on Twitter I guess supposedly ninja
called me out challenged me to a fight
you guys know for years and years me and
each have been rivals he's talked all
day in the past meaty suits and now I'm
getting the opportunity to back it up I
just want to get in the ring with this
fool and literally
and like I just want to end it despite t
food acknowledging that it was a mistake
and that ninjas account got hacked he
jumped on the opportunity to stir up
some drama rekindle an old beef and make
a run at this which seems a little
opportunistic to me don't get me wrong
there's obviously some attention-seeking
going on here but at the same time this
call-out is savage ninja before you know
you crawl up the mixer even more and die
even harder like you need to get your
numbers up let's do this fight you need
it more than I do I mean let's be honest
two numbers here you're down way harder
than me that's for damn sure he even
goes as far as alleging that amidst
therefore guy rivalry in the past
ninja tried to get his twitch account
banned now he didn't provide any details
about that accusation but that is a
pretty severe claim he's been trying to
tear me down he's been talking I my bad
I never mentioned this to anyone before
but he actually did try to get me
permanently banned behind my back I
literally ruined my career
and honestly I should have called him
out then for some reason I didn't I just
let it slide he finishes the call out by
offering the fight in anyway ninja wants
MMA boxing whatever and I'm getting an
opportunity now to try to tear me down
in the ring I don't care if UFC MMA
whatever the case I'll open Paul it went
down it went well like why don't we do
it like let's run it like I'm not scared
if anything he's scared you know I'm
saying and as soon as ninja got his
Twitter account back he made a well
predictably ninja tweet saying that he
wasn't gonna fight T foo and that T foo
was just trying to capitalize on this
drama now with all the information this
is obviously a lot to take in and even
after watching TVs video it's hard to
understand exactly how serious he is but
with that said there is a precedent for
content creators base fighting on the
internet for years YouTube stars have
racked up millions of views by beefing
with each other
writing diss tracks and then making
music videos a note
foolish you'll be looking does it
contain the ass-whoopin and then back in
2018 ksi and Jake Paul got in the ring
for what was the first of now to actual
boxing matches and coming off the heels
of their second fight you've got to
think that T foo is trying to capitalize
off the fandom for drama that these
fights generate what's more is that this
rivalry seems pretty legit like I
actually believe that T fo and ninja
don't like each other it doesn't feel
like some of this other made up YouTube
[ __ ] T foo and ninjas rivalry dates all
the way back to when they were battling
in pub G and H ones Edwin and that beef
has certainly lingered into the four
night world as they have become two of
the biggest streamers in the world over
the last two years no matter how nice
they into the kid he's always hated me
so I don't really know what to tell you
guys at the heart of this long-standing
battle between them is oddly a case of
negativity versus positivity t foo has
well he never really shiz away from
complaining about fortnight or anything
for that matter he's always got some
random criticism about why the game
sucks or he's dog [ __ ] to take a phrase
out of his book and well ninja being the
all frills pg-13 corporate minded
creator that he is well he doesn't
always like that in fact ninja has
called out multiple content creators
over the last year for this exact same
sentiment including his very public
ongoing beef with TSM creator Dakotas to
me this is honestly a pretty classic
kind of beef the kid friendly guy who
sells t-shirts with his name on them at
Walmart versus the guy who jumps off
reservoirs and well at least makes
himself look like a badass on YouTube
it's a little bit of Hollywood drama in
the gaming world and whether it's legit
or not I am actually kind of here for it
look some of you have to watch sports
right rivalries are fun to watch unfold
and you can't
you wouldn't spend $10 to watch these
two skinny gamers get in the ring and
hash out their differences
so who you got ninja or Tifa a ninja you
like talk behind my back you either get
in a ring and be a man and let's do this
or like just shut them meet your and
never talk to never talk about my name
ever again I mean just coming out like
he's like the mayor of the city right
he's like shaking everybody's hands
making sure that everyone's having a
good time and see if we like just try to
look as cool as possible even though
he's like a little cringe presentation
that's that's T Fu's gimmick right he's
like jumping off things he's
skateboarding down [ __ ] hills and
like always like bleeding on YouTube
somehow the ninja it's like you know the
[ __ ] you say to me a little [ __ ]